[Music]
ensue happy news submitted by Joe Malian
immigrant tamale Joe mammalian you can
now file a lawsuit by simply swiping
right in an app
oh no why it's expensive though like I
hope it's like $10,000 so you really
have to think about that [ __ ] feel
free all [ __ ] lawyers could
pick it up and then they could make
money from it ok so this app is called
do not pay and should be called I'm a
[ __ ] yeah 21 year olds founder it's 21
year old found her name's Josh Josh what
Flickr wits
Josh Browder of the Blanco Nature he's
Blanco he was lucky enough you're
staying Asian for Branko or a Blanco the
you guys have white guy Caucasian yeah
he's uh he's been labeled the Robin Hood
of the internet because when he was 18
he created a bot that helped people
fight parking tickets in New York London
and CSI and then he later created
another bot to help people sue Equifax
after that data breach I'll talk and of
soup it is yeah yeah yeah I like that
but people gonna use it for like some
wack suing - yeah
apologies I'm a funny too early yeah so
this is more for like small claims court
oh you have to sue your homie when like
you spot them they didn't pay you back
shit's like clash accident oh no I love
small claims court is so Petty and
stupid I guess
it can be class action stuff too so you
can like you can look through things
that like class-action lawsuits shopping
for lawsuits yes I like if it affected
you you could be like oh I want to be
part of that class action I got $7 from
Toyota
I didn't cash it though cuz I felt bad
why'd you feel bad okay it's seven
dollars and it's like I don't know car
companies are gonna have problems
yeah and then I'll do it on purpose that
tossed [ __ ] you up on purpose yeah if it
was seven million Dena I won't feel bad
for me all right
I have morals girl sorry and bills to
pay right if it's seven dollars I can't
take that money move it seven million
hell yeah I'll [ __ ] take the [ __ ] out
of that money they got plenty of money
coming in yeah so I'm gonna show you
guys a video clip of how this app works
Oh curiouser this will has no other apps
I mean it's the last page yes it's like
these are all different types of things
and you get to choose the amount that
you're suing for uh-huh and then like
for example this one sue anyone I'm
super easy like step by step like it
guide you through it put your name in
put your agile rayon oh I feel about
what did you make a fake identity you
better make a very verified identity how
much do you want to sue for like in this
example here it's this person didn't get
their rent rent deposit back from the
landlord so then they're even asking
like you know all these things how about
like a like a sewer ometer like that
tells you highly unlikely to get that
money bro that's high they tell you like
this is very fair yeah cuz like what's
preventing a landlord from suing your
ass back how are these people who's
gonna be costly suing each other yeah
well you're on that well so am i [ __ ]
right right yeah they should make a
countersuit app yeah then they're saying
like this is all done and then they
provide you the forms for you to send to
the person you're suing and then says
like check back in five days for the
next test
yeah it has like all the forms filled
out for you after just answer
good question that would be nice so I
don't know what I would sue for I have
an idea what I want to sue for um like
breach of contract stuff or like people
didn't pay you and you had like have you
guys ever sued anybody never me too I
mean I hope this is used for good but I
think just my person is excited it feels
like there's just gonna be people that
want to take advantage of it and just
start suing people had the Asians aren't
the suing type I don't think yeah well I
had to file a lawsuit against the the
truck that obliterated my car yeah
because I was without that car so I was
I paid like 1,100 bucks a month for that
car right and that was only about a year
and a half I didn't have that car yeah
oh so yeah I just wanted them them to
pay for the [ __ ] just for the the
money I've been losing so I made just
wouldn't so you bitched out David why I
had to I'm just kidding but that makes
sense you know yeah that's like $17,000
you know perfect so if they were acting
as if I wanted like the world from them
you know what I mean I was like no you
[ __ ] obliterated my car at least pay
for it to get fixed you know you could
do that no I got that money oh you did
oh nice it only took a year no what I
saw I like that stuff I think is normal
what I don't like is I let's say you go
to a restaurant right they give you your
coffee and there it might be a hair in
it and then they go comma Seuss this
place for like ten thousand dollars when
they're like wait I could just give you
another coffee yeah you know but people
are so passive-aggressive instead of
just getting another coffee and fixing
the situation like [ __ ] these people and
they sue for amounts that are [ __ ]
ridiculous I hope that there's enough
like checks and [ __ ] in this stuff so
it's not you can't abuse it and they
know like hey that seems kind of a
reasonable buddy true so this one
college student said that he used this
app to to appeal for more than one
hundred and thirty dollars an overdraft
and wire transfer fees from his bank and
he actually won that and so he was just
like yeah it was pretty crazy because I
thought banks had the upper hand like
you know the VA just give you fees and
you're just screwed and you just have to
pay them but then by using yeah app he
was able to appeal it and get his money
back so they just want to settle
sometimes the companies to but I think
this is dope because you know it's a
hassle to get a lawyer it's a hassle to
study the law on your own and it takes
so much time not only that but they're
saying that if your issue is like the
low ten thousand dollars that no lawyers
gonna help you and you do help you
they're gonna take half of it yeah and
it's like pointless yeah yeah that makes
a lot of sense yes this app allows users
to sue a defendant for up to $25,000
I'm gonna sue all my friends I'm gonna
get this up you see right back
I probably use them to break a lease
even dive into phone damn I know someone
I want to sue Oh Jess no for emotional
distress no you said shits and giggles
damn small claims court is probably the
I used to love [ __ ] Judge Judy judge
yeah yeah this because some of these
people are the low lowest piece of trash
human beings ever be like there was have
you seen this like really popular clip
of this guy he basically stole this
girl's purse and she's asking for for
him to pay up for everything that was
lost in it so the judge ass it's like oh
so basically she's supposed to say
what's in the purse sunglasses whatever
he goes excuse me your honor there were
no sunglasses in there no he was just
tampons and three dollars
it wasn't crowd to like admitting to it
judge judy is the highest paid
television star yeah oh yeah her diary
she's still on here yeah yeah she's
still I mean she's still a judge you
know so it's I watch her on YouTube TV
do you guys ever ever try to get out of
the parking ticket or like just tickets
that you get from caught the driver
battle or I heard people do that I just
don't I never done it there's a lot of
ways to do it
I didn't so mine
I was supposed to show up to court to
fight it right to appeal it so the day
that I scheduled because you're supposed
to schedule that far in advance or some
sure like that so I did that and then I
was gonna show up or I did show up and
my cop didn't show up yeah it depends if
you want to deal with it or would you
rather pay a lawyer and you pay less cuz
that's what I did I think my focus [ __ ]
man yeah that's a that's a good gamble
but you just never know if they'll show
I always just pay I got a I got a ticket
out of Lodi which is like two hours away
from Sacramento about and basically the
cop game the ticket cuz you know he sees
where you're from was already from from
Sacramento yes I meant to give you a
ticket football habla it was for like
some [ __ ] speaking I was not
speeding and I think he assumed that I
was gonna come and I was like no I'm
gonna fight I drove all the way to hours
they come there he didn't show up
Wow I'm petty as [ __ ] dude I [ __ ]
drove two hours in I'm not doing that
[ __ ] he literally gave me like the same
day huh did you come back the same day
no it was scheduled for like a month out
or something like that no I mean like
when you drove up to for the court date
and then you came right back or did you
stay with your family because if you
have family oh no this is my live
designer Mona oh yeah when I live in
second but that's some like Pride [ __ ]
yeah I was like I'm not getting this
ticket it went all the way they keep
even show up
you're just cussing Korean the whole
timer driver was speeding
I was not speeding I'd be like running a
red light ticket because I was making a
right on a red light which you can but
then the camera flashed and then I still
had to pay it though like you have to
pay money first and then they you get it
back but then I showed up and all the
day that I showed up it was like I was
ready I was gonna say my case and
they're like for these people here all
of you are dismissed and then what I
heard that the city does is they just
kind of send out these like letters to
hope that people pay for them and not
fight them
it's so [ __ ] Shady because while I
was doing research I was like that's
[ __ ] up so like if you show up you
know you'll get your money back but
they're hoping that you don't that's how
most of the life [ __ ] works like you
have to always like take care of it
first you know and then like that's
what's up they expect people not to
follow through that's why 3-month trials
and all that
yeah you know what I mean because you
signed up for and you don't cancel it
dude I'm like as soon as I get those
emails I'm like cancel in them all you
can do now is all online like thank God
man like [ __ ] I got a speeding ticket
and then I don't want to point on my
record I need that stuff and then I just
hired a lawyer online because it was
gonna cost me like a thousand dollars
for all that [ __ ] and then they took
care of it for like a couple hundred so
it's like I rather pay a little bit
it was like 800 bucks and then I ended
up doing traffic school yes you do that
[ __ ] you want to get a little bit
through traffic school is so easy though
online like you're literally just eating
a sandwich going it takes the power or
you can find a Chinese place that
they'll just sign off for you that's
just a legal my dad knows how a place
like that all right
no makes sense now I [ __ ] they
actually need the [ __ ] tracking to
actually do yeah yeah I'm like the worst
person at a read oh god nobody told me
this the whole time I did some zone I
think the driving school that I went to
if I took the written test this is like
way back in when I was young and [ __ ]
like they gave me they gave me the
dislike the six different test state he
give you
they had him already like with the
heavies yeah it was a Korean was a
Korean school no I was just like some
Armenian spot or something yeah same
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]